salut tout le monde nouveau podcast
profil draft 2023 on vous présente
l'essentiel sur un joueur en une
vingtaine de minutes et pour ce podcast
ce sera jares Walker
né le 4 septembre 2003 à Baltimore il
jouait pour les Houston Kuga cette année
en ncbbelais il a fait une seule année
avant de se présenter à la draft 2
mètres sans chaussures selon les mesures
du NBA combine 112 kg de mètres 18
d'envergure belle bête 4e sur notre
bigboard à l'heure à laquelle on
enregistre c'est-à-dire le vendredi 16
juin chez ispienne et veringer il est 7e
au niveau des classements de valeur des
joueurs et the athletic la 9e pour en
parler nous avons FD et nous avons
Hugues salut les gars bonjour bonsoir à
toutes et à tous et comme d'habitude on
commence avec une petite biographie bien
sentie c'est toi qui t'en occupe FD
effectivement Joyce Walker comme
celui-là dit il est originaire d'une
petite bourgade de Pennsylvanie tout
proche de Baltimore il est issu d'une
famille athlétique sa sœur a joué au
volley-ball à l'université sa sœur
niveau actuellement à Saint-Joseph aussi
au basket à l'université alors il y a
énormément de joueurs qui sont des High
School finances qu'on découvre et qui
explose au cours de leur de leur lycée
Jaris au cœur c'est plutôt un middle
schoolfinum c'est à dire qu'avant même
d'arriver au lycée il était sur sur les
plates de tous les scouts notamment High
School de sorte qu'il a rejoint l'usine
à prospect de l'Académie IMG en Floride
Académie qui a sorti énormément de
joueurs NBA et donc il a pu faire ses
armes au contraire de plusieurs
intérieurs avec qui il a pu travailler
les rebonds défensifs ça se voit
aujourd'hui dans sa carrière NCA
notamment zachidées Marc Williams Moussa
Diabaté forcément il a commencé à faire
du bruit en Floride de sorte que Houston
a très très vite placé ses pions sur lui
et donc ils ont dévolu un assistant
coach presque presque que pour lui et
ils l'ont suivi pendant deux ans pour
s'assurer ses services et c'est donc
tout naturellement qui s'est engagé avec
Houston et donc le volat arrive à
Houston une saison où il n'a absolument
pas déçu et il arrive aux portes de la
draft avec une hype monstrueuse
effectivement grosse hype pour Jared
Walker dans une équipe de Houston Hugh
ou ça jouait bien où il y avait de
l'expérience qu'est-ce qu'on lui demande
d'être faire dans cette équipe là quel
rôle il avait offensivement et
défensivement
qui qui visait le titre qui a fini
premier site pour la pour la masse
manette donc dans dans les quatre
meilleurs équipes c'était une équipe
très expérimentée menée par wraps nous
sommes dans une mine major l'américaine
qui est une major pour le coup plutôt
côté une équipe avec beaucoup
d'expérience il joue aux côtés de
joueurs alors qui ont pas forcément tous
une carrière NBA mais qui auront une
carrière pro ou traite atlantique on
pense à Marc saicer qui candidat à la
draft on pensait à Jamal on pense à toi
et Marc qui va entamer une troisième
année une scie et qui rentre dans une
dans une amerger et ce qui est assez
marquant juste au niveau de la confiance
qui lui était donné c'est que il y avait
d'autres
French man qui était très attendus on
pense à Terence Arsenault par exemple ou
Emmanuel Shop et il jouait beaucoup
moins ils avaient beaucoup moins de
responsabilités et ils étaient beaucoup
moins bon
Houston foot comprendre que c'est une
des meilleures défenses du pays c'est la
meilleure défense de la ligne A3 points
enfin du côtoyer extérieur de toute la
NCA on lui a demandé d'être un second
rideau ce qui explique les stats au
contre on lui a demandé d'être un
rebondeur féroce on lui a demandé de
sécuriser ce jeu là et il a pu prouver
on va dans ses forces après au niveau de
son iTunes qui comprenait toutes les
rotations avec un une polyvalence de
système défensif on avait de la zone on
avait beaucoup de Trappes on avait on
avait parfois du de la trappe de la zone
qui évolue sur Job donc c'était vraiment
complexe il était très très bon là
dedans et puis offensivement on donne
beaucoup de beaucoup de munitions à ma
que c'est ce match qui était les les
premières options extérieures et puis
lui il était là en poseur d'écran
rebours offensif budback et il a pu
montrer une un début de tiers notamment
sur du pic and pop et ça ça va être une
projection dont on va sur laquelle on va
s'intéresser dans les minutes qui
suivent voilà donc on le je l'ai dit en
introduction il est quand même vu
unanimement classé dans des dans un top
10 de cette draft NBA 2023
si on se met dans la peau FD du du de la
personne qui va le drafter pourquoi on
draft jazz Walker en top 10 pour quelle
qualité qu'est-ce qui va lui acheter
c'est quoi son ticket d'entrée NBA
son ticket d'entrée NBA se sont
potentiel défensif et je dis potentiel
parce que il a déjà un niveau de base et
il arrive déjà avec des outils qui sont
de très haut niveau mais son vrai ticket
d'entrée pour le top 10 c'est le
potentiel son ticket d'entrée en NBA
tout court c'est la défense qu'il a
aujourd'hui mais son ticket d'entrée
pour aller très très haut dans la draft
c'est un potentiel c'est un joueur qui
aujourd'hui comme la comme l'a dit Hugh
a défendu plutôt sur les sur le poste 4
voir sur le poste 5 mais qui a quand
même montré des capacités notamment
grâce à ces outils athlétiques des
capacités pour pour rester proche des
extérieurs ou plutôt des postes 3 une
dissuasion en deuxième rideau mais
également une lecture des rotations
défensives qui ont fait de lui en fait
un excellent joueur un excellent
défenseur loin de la balle notamment sur
des situations de pick and roll ou en
fait c'était c'était le low man donc le
joueur le joueur qui venait en aide sur
le roller il est excellent sur ces
situations où il peut aller le taguer
mais à la fois défendre sur la sur la
passe qui peut aller à l'opposé sur un
tir à trois points donc vraiment il
montre une maturité défensive qui est
impressionnante à son âge et qui coupait
à ses qualités athlétiques en font
vraiment un profil défensif très très
intéressant et c'est ça qui va le faire
drafté en NBA
Hugues est-ce que offensivement il y a
des choses pour lesquelles on le draft
puisque c'est quand même assez rare les
les héros offensifs dans la ligue
d'autant plus choisi top 10 de draft
offensivement tu vas avoir le fantasme
forcément de l'Intérieur qui peut garder
le jeu qui va donner du spaceing alors
au moment au niveau des pourcentages à
trois points c'est comment dire on est
que je veux
34,734,7 %, ce qui est correct avec
quasiment que du catch and shoot mais au
niveau des eaux il y a vraiment des des
des spots qui sont privilégiés notamment
45 degrés à gauche 45 droit et c'est pas
un joueur très efficace dans le catch
and shoot dans le corner ça montre que
tu as un joueur de pitchen popo qui va
te donner ça et puis par son sa densité
physique et sa capacité
à finir près du panier 70% sous le
cercle on va avoir un joueur de pit and
roll qui va pouvoir très vite monter
terminer fort et puis si jamais il y a
des copains qui envoient des briques par
sa capacité aussi à aller chercher des
rebonds offensifs en box-out par
l'envergure et par la compréhension tout
simple du rebond de pouvoir être voilà
une pression supplémentaire
du cercle maintenant offensivement on va
on va avoir un dribble à développer on
va ça va peut-être être un des premiers
joueurs drafté de cette cuvée qui ne
pourra pas se créer son propre tir
dans les trois quatre cinq premières
années où on sait que le top 6 7 on
essaie d'avoir des des shots makers
Walker et pas dans ce profil là
pour pour son rôle dès l'année prochaine
en fait je d'habitude cette partie vient
plus tard mais je pense ça va être
intéressant de l'aborder avant qu'on
parle de des choses à travailler
qu'est-ce qu'on va lui demander de faire
FD l'année prochaine finalement on va
lui demander d'être ce c'était lié un
peu polyvalent ce gars qui peut défendre
sur les trois quatre les Small Ball five
en défense et et offensivement qu'est-ce
qu'il va faire il va juste poser des
écrans et rôle
alors pas seulement pas seulement enfin
j'espère pas pour lui effectivement il y
a tout le côté énergiser défensif ça
c'est sûr mais moi j'aimerais le voir
encore plus qu'à l'université encore
plus il y a Houston où il était souvent
avec un deuxième poste 5 et donc il
posait très peu d'écran j'ai vraiment
envie de voir dans un spaceing NBA ce
qui va donner en poseur d'écran que ce
soit pour rouler et utiliser ses
qualités athlétiques ou bien pour poper
et donc là assouvir le fantasme de tir à
trois points
maintenant sur il a quand même montré
qu'il avait des qualités sur le spot-up
quand il ne tirait pas à driver on
parlera de on parlera du skill qu'il
faut qu'il faut développer mais en voilà
en termes offensivement on peut attendre
de bons écrans
du rôle
et le reste viendra plus tard le reste
viendra pas en année une donc pour
l'instant une heure défensif poseur
d'écran et puis dépasse
un passeur de connexion mais pas pas
forcément de très haut niveau tout de
suite moi j'ai trouvé très bon sur les
passes j'ai pas vu énormément de films
mais j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait des
anticipations assez fulgurantes par
rapport à par rapport à sa jeunesse
Hugues je sais que tu valides pour les
écrans je sais que c'est quelque chose
que tu regardes beaucoup en fait hip-hop
beaucoup en fait il fait il fait il
glisse on glissait beaucoup les écrans à
Houston donc c'est assez difficile à
évaluer mais c'est vrai que quand on lui
rentre dedans il prend tellement de
place que ça ça crée de l'espace pour le
gars qui prend pour le porteur de ballon
quoi
ouais il a montré soit on slip
effectivement on glisse comme tu le dis
et derrière on va pas marquer l'écran et
il va pas il va pas forcément créer un
écart mais il va poper il peut poper des
deux côtés donc effectivement ça ouvre
de l'espace et puis une fois qu'il se
Lipp il a cette capacité partir sur une
main et derrière il a un flotteur alors
il a un flotteur sur lequel il abuse moi
je j'en ai marre de ce flottes en main
droite un peu un peu catastrophique mais
il a il a des outils là du toucher qu'on
regarde dans le dans le mi distance
on a un joueur qui est quand même assez
à l'aise qui a envie d'en prendre
beaucoup donc il y a une vraie
polyvalence offensive et oui comme tu le
dis comme c'est il fait c'est un mètre
cube quoi c'est un frigo pour faire le
tour ça prend ça prend du temps et j'ai
aucun souci à projeter ça au niveau
supérieur et je pense que ce qui est
important quand tu posais la question de
l'ADN c'est que c'est un joueur plancher
c'est un jour safe on sait que je West
Walker peu importe où il va il va élever
des la première année
le niveau de son équipe juste par sa
compréhension défensive ça maturité
physique sans maturité dans le jeu et le
comment dire le le package de base qu'il
apporte donc une équipe qui va vouloir
passer un cap rapidement qui en a
peut-être marre de d'être dans les fonds
de la de la NBA qui a déjà pris son
Frances player entre guillemets à la
draft il y a un ou deux ans peut se
jeter sur Walker pour ça qu'est-ce qu'on
développe chez lui quel est toi tu le
draft TFD quelle est la priorité à
donner au
coaching développement de staff
ça dépend un peu ce que tu veux en faire
je pense qu'il y a le il y a toujours le
souci de est-ce qu'on veut plutôt le
développer pour qu'il soit un poste 4 3
donc à ce moment là tu vas plutôt
développer son pour moi son attaque de
clos out
son premier dribble son premier pas et
sa capacité à aller finir au panier si
par contre tu veux vraiment le passer
dans un côté plutôt poste 5 poseur
d'écran à ce moment là tu tu lui donnes
plein de répétitions sur pic Caroll et
tu appuies sur la qualité que tu que tu
mettais en valeur avant son playmaking
et donc tu l'utilises comme un comme un
joueur de shortroll comme un joueur à
qui tu vas donner pourquoi pas quelques
isolations post-bac quand il y aura des
mismatch et tu regardes si il est
capable de faire les passes de décalage
donc ça dépend vraiment de l'équipe qui
est le qui le draft et quel projet ils
ont avec lui est-ce que c'est de faire
un ailier de très grande taille avec un
impact physique très important ou bien
plutôt le développer dans un profil de
Small Ball five à ce moment là du coup
tu le développes même prendre vraiment
en poseur d'écran et le reste sera du
bonus
Hugues est-ce que parce que il est petit
quand même de mettre en chaussures c'est
pas très est-ce qu'il a le le est-ce
qu'il est une menace au Cercle
offensivement
est-ce qu'il est capable d'être une
menace de lobe voilà alors de bien finir
quand il est le le
comment on appelle ça quand il est dans
le dans la pocket passe quoi il est
capable de ça alors il monte il a une
comment dire il y a une belle partie de
qualité et puis surtout il a une comme
une très bonne détente sèche donc on l'a
vu réceptionner des balles fait des
ballons dans la peinture sous le panier
se retourner et te donne que sur la tête
sans même vraiment sauter c'est un
joueur qui qui est très puissant qui
encore une fois sont tous kilos je suis
pas sur qu'on va le développer sur un
petit pivot je le vois bien en
complément c'est ça redevient à la mode
en NBA on pense à des mecs comme grent
Williams par exemple qui vont être dans
ce genre de profil là au PJ Washington
du côté de Charlotte je pense qu'on va
plus qu'on va plus aller là-dedans il a
un peu de de jeux au niveau du poste bas
alors pour le moment on est capable de
punir du Miss match quoi ouais c'est ça
on est sur sur des choses simples mais
qu'on pourra travailler dans un second
temps quand on disait joueur plancher
voilà le poste bas on a un enroulé ma
droite on a roulé main gauche capable de
passer soit sur la ligne de fond soit
dans l'axe et puis si jamais il rate
encore une fois rebond offensif et je
retourne on a vu plein de situations où
il rate un tiers de tir trois tiers près
du panier puis recharpe le robot Hero
shop le rebond et puis il le met où il
le ressort parce qu'il a une très bonne
lecture de jeu donc moi j'irai plus sur
un
ailier fort très fort
développement Paul mille sabre Williams
ce genre de choses là plutôt que petit
pivot et pourquoi pas sur des sur des
situations play-offs qu'on lui très
rapidement mais peut-être jouer petit 5
mais pour moi c'est moins probable dans
les dans les premières années
FD on va s'arrêter sur son point fort
enfin il retourner plutôt parce que tu
parles de son potentiel défensif on
parle de quoi en fait on parle de quel
potentiel défensif on parle de quel
modèle de joueur
tu l'as tu l'as évoqué tout à l'heure
mais sans forcément citer des joueurs
mais mais en termes d'impact pour
prendre un gatop 10 principalement sur
la défense il faut que ça soit vraiment
exceptionnel est-ce que est-ce que tu
vois ce joueur là et pour quelle raison
c'est une question un peu compliqué pour
moi je vois un potentiel de de Romer de
joueurs or ballon de très très haut
niveau un petit peu de enfin très
disruptif que tu mets sur un sur un
post-4 ou sur un poste 5 qui a pas
forcément de tirer donc il est pas
forcément une menace et que tu de à qui
tu demandes vraiment d'être dans la
disruption à la fois des drives à la
fois des lignes de passe
pour moi le le c'est un très bon
défenseur d'isolation aujourd'hui en NCA
c'est un très très bon de défenseur
d'isolation
ma limite pour moi pour le voir des
formes sur des sur les meilleurs postes
3 et les postes 4 en NBA ça va être sa
navigation d'écran autant en isolation
je me fais pas de souci sur n'importe
quel jour enfin sur la plupart des
postes 3-4 en NBA autant sur des
situations de pick and roll où il va
être le défenseur du du porteur de Balme
à part switcher j'ai du mal à le voir
dans sa navigation de l'écran tout
simplement parce que comme l'a dit Hulk
c'est un frigo donc c'est un très bon
poseur d'écran mais de l'autre côté il
est facile à stopper puisque il prend
beaucoup de c'est très large donc on
parle pour moi d'un excellent défenseur
en isolation un très bon défenseur au
poste bas et hors ballon quelqu'un qui
fait des bonnes rotations et qui a un
vrai potentiel de distribution donc ça
te fait quand même un profil un profil
très très large seul petit bémol pour
moi sur la navigation d'écran mais par
contre tu peux très bien tu peux très
bien
pallier ce défaut en switch en tout
simplement et comme ça tu donnes pas tu
donnes pas forcément de dispatch ce qui
est souvent le cas dans les quand le
niveau de jeu augmente et que les
défenses se resserrent
est-ce que tu as noté des choses dans le
dans la psychologie du garçon tu sois
attitude sur le terrain où en interview
bon on l'a on l'a compris parce que vous
disiez et ça se voit assez vite quand on
le regarde jouer c'est quelqu'un qui est
très intelligent sur un terrain de
basket maintenant ça veut pas c'est pas
gage de de stabilité psychologique
qu'en est-il
alors j'ai pas vu de comment dire
énormément de de choses qui sont qui
sont marquantes très bon coéquipiers
comme comme c'était sous Nice plus c'est
coéquipiers qui en parle mieux son coach
qui dit voilà moi sur le terrain j'ai
pas l'impression d'avoir un freshman et
des vétérans j'ai l'impression d'avoir
plein de vétérans
et puis énorme combativité défensive
toujours toujours envie de comment dire
de faire gagner la défense et pas
justement son Dieu à l'individuel je
m'explique que j'avais fait un live
dessus j'avais dit billwassol serait
très fier de lui tu vois c'est le genre
de joueur il y a il y a un tiers il
prend le bac ça autre il voit qu'il va
pas avoir forcément le rebond et bah
juste il va faire une petite touche de
balle pour que son coéquipier puisse
sécuriser le rebond que la transition
elle se passe très vite il a pas
d'orgueil là-dessus pareil il est sous
le panier rebond offensif et au lieu de
remonter je vois la petite pocket passe
et je la prends donc c'est un joueur qui
qui joue pas pour ces stats qui jouent
vraiment pour la pour la victoire et qui
lorsqu'il est en lorsqu'il est en pleine
difficulté il se frustre pas il va
continuer les actions suivantes et
toujours bien passé donc moi je suis
vraiment impressionné par sa maturité
sur le terrain après à l'extérieur j'ai
pas j'ai pas assez vite et je suis pas
dans les dans les petits tiroirs de
Houston malheureusement
est-ce qu'il y a un est-ce qu'il y a un
truc à débloquer au-delà de ce qu'on a
dit tout à l'heure sur les rôles
offensifs et sur ses limites défensives
est-ce que il y a on parle d'un plancher
sur est-ce que le plafond est très élevé
et à quel point il a des chances de
l'atteindre est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a
un plafond à la je fais pas la même
taille donc évidemment non mais elle a
déjà un Jackson FD
le fait qu'il fasse pas la même taille
et quand même un souci je pense
non par contre pour moi le vrai swing
skill c'est le tir j'y crois pas
forcément mais par contre il est en
progression constante depuis son il est
arrivé en début d'année avec des
pourcentages qui étaient pas qui était
pas excellents et puis on le voit monter
en confiance et gagner en précisément se
sentir franc par exemple ça reste ça
reste chez qui
donc voilà le tir pour moi et le swinsky
le plus important plutôt dans un profil
comme l'a dit comme l'a dit plutôt Paul
windsap si on reste dans les
comparaisons plutôt pour lui ça que que
jarret Jackson
oui donc tu crois
il peut faire une belle carrière mais il
sera peut-être pas il sera jamais le top
le meilleur ou le deuxième meilleur
joueur d'une équipe qui va au titre je
parle offensivement
le
joueur ou le deuxième jour le plus
important de son équipe dans son rôle et
de son impact et de la façon dont il va
changer il va changer vraiment ta
défense par sa présence par sa qualité
de rotation etc mais ce sera pas ce sera
pas une star offensive au mieux c'est un
joueur qui devient un excellent comment
dire jour de pic and roll pic and pop et
qui développe vraiment ce rôle avec un
peu plus de polyvalence André pour
terminer de et de postes bas voilà pour
moi c'est c'est un lieutenant plus plus
d'une bonne équipe et
encore on se commence le dit en off
quand tu es genre enfin toutes les
équipes en fait ont besoin d'un dialyse
Walker
pour la draft tu vois tu te dis Houston
bah ouais il faut être folker tu dis
ouais tu fais bah ouais il faut
interviewer tu vois dis toi tu dis là
ils sont un diwei sur le cœur d'être une
très bonne équipe et ça montre la valeur
du gars devant peut-être des joueurs
plus qu'il est individuellement et qui
ont plus de potentiel All Stars entre
guillemets
le potentiel enfin la probabilité
d'échec est moins dense c'est ce que ce
qu'on entend dans ce que vous dites et
c'est donc le résumé de enfin c'est
l'essentiel sur jerse Walker qu'on vous
a donné le joueur de Houston donc qui
n'a pas encore 20 ans qui est dans
l'année de ses 20 ans et qui devrait
être choisi dans le top 10 de la
prochaine draft voilà pour son profil
tous les autres sont à consulter sur
soit YouTube soit les plateformes
d'écoute Deezer Spotify et compagnie et
puis il y a évidemment la version écrite
sur envergure pensée haut ciao tout le
monde